[Música]
hace de ve acá no no se trata de un
abecedario desordenado son vitaminas y
son los bloques que mantienen al cuerpo
funcionando las vitaminas son compuestos
orgánicos que hay que ingerir en
pequeñas cantidades para seguir
funcionando son las obreras que
construyen defienden y mantienen el
cuerpo ayudan a formar los músculos y
huesos a usar los nutrientes captar y
usar energía y sanar heridas si aún
dudas del valor de las vitaminas piense
en los marineros de antaño que no tenían
acceso a frutas y verduras frescas y
ricas en vitaminas contra ian escorbuto
pero la vitamina c abundante en frutas y
verduras era el antídoto contra esta
enfermedad si bien las bacterias los
hongos y las plantas producen sus
propias vitaminas nuestro cuerpo no y
hay que obtener las de otras fuentes
entonces como las incorporamos las
vitaminas son de dos tipos liposolubles
e hidrosolubles y según el tipo se
determina como el cuerpo las trans
y almacena y elimina el exceso las
hidrosolubles son la vitamina c y los 8
tipos de vitaminas del grupo b cada una
con una función determinada están
disueltas en el contenido acuoso de las
frutas verduras y granos lo que
significa que su asimilación es
relativamente directa
una vez en el sistema se digieren los
alimentos y las vitaminas que tienen van
directamente al torrente sanguíneo para
las vitaminas liposolubles disueltas en
la grasa de alimentos como los lácteos y
los aceites
este viaje hacia la sangre es más
complicado estas vitaminas pasan por el
estómago y el intestino donde una
sustancia ácida llamada bilis secretada
por el hígado fracciona la grasa y la
prepara para su absorción a través de la
pared intestinal como las vitaminas
liposolubles no pueden usar el medio
acuoso sanguíneo necesitan ayuda para
trasladarse y eso viene de las proteínas
que se unen a las vitaminas y hacen de
mensajeros transportando las a través de
la sangre por todo el cuerpo
la diferencia entre las vitaminas
hidrosolubles y las liposolubles
determina cómo llegan a la sangre y cómo
se almacena y eliminan del cuerpo la
capacidad de nuestro cuerpo de
distribuir las vitaminas hidrosolubles
por la sangre tan fácilmente implica que
la mayoría puede eliminarse con igual
facilidad por los riñones por ello la
mayoría de las vitaminas hidrosolubles
se deben reponer a diario a partir de
los alimentos que ingerimos pero las
vitaminas liposolubles tiene un efecto
más duradero pues pueden acumularse en
el tejido hepático y adiposo el cuerpo
trata estas partes como una despensa
donde almacena las vitaminas y las
consume cuando es necesario
aclarada a la logística de transporte y
almacenaje las vitaminas pueden hacer su
trabajo
algunas como muchas del grupo b forman
co encinas cuyo trabajo es ayudar a las
enzimas a liberar la energía de los
alimentos con la vitamina c podemos
combatir infecciones y producir colágeno
base del tejido óseo y dental y que
curan heridas
la vitamina a ayuda a hacer leucocitos
clave en la defensa del cuerpo ayuda a
formar los huesos y mejorar la vista
cuidando de los fotorreceptores la
vitamina d absorbe el calcio y fósforo
necesarios para el desarrollo óseo y la
vitamina e actúa como antioxidante
eliminando elementos que pueden dañar
las células por último con la vitamina k
podemos coagular la sangre puesto que
ayuda a crear las proteínas que hacen
este trabajo sin esta variedad de
vitaminas enfrentamos diferencias que
causan problemas como cansancio daño
neurológico cardiopatías y enfermedades
como el raquitismo y el escorbuto por
otro lado el exceso de vitaminas puede
causar intoxicación aquí muere el mito
que cargarse de suplementos vitamínicos
es buena idea en realidad todo es
cuestión de mantener el equilibrio y dar
con la combinación perfecta de vitaminas